I don't know the budget of porn tube is
but this might be the most expensive
porn tube commercial ever sex tape so
sex tape is a movie starring Jason Segel
and Cameron Diaz they make a sex tape
together then the sex tape gets uploaded
to a cloud server and then distributed
to these iPad devices and now they got
to go on a scavenger hunt to stop their
friends from seeing the sex tape
ultimately this married couples
searching for Horcruxes that's the movie
the movies chuckle worthy in a few parts
but ultimately this movie isn't as funny
as I wanted it to be which I say that
about a lot of comedies because a lot of
comedies are not as funny as I think
they could be it's a movie about a
couple making a sex video and that video
gets distributed to their friends wait a
minute it's not a tape tape is like tape
tape should be called like sex mp4 or
something yeah whatever you just think
that would be funnier than it is one of
the problems with this movie is that
every scene is just a bit too long this
set up to the movies a little too long
the scene where they're gonna have sex
and they'd finally reached the
conclusion where we're gonna make this
sex video that's too long so long in
fact the Jason Segel loses his boner
yeah when this scene goes on for so long
that the character in the movie loses
his erection rest assure the audience
has lost their erection for the movie
also and dude come on if you're having
trouble reaching to your secret stash
you know it's - I'm talking about that
stash that every married guy has oh it's
true there's no shame in it it's just
true it's just long drawn out and at
first you chuckle and then you're like
all right get on with it wrong this one
joke still holy [ __ ] the dialogue
between the characters in the scenes
that were too long went on for too long
also the dialogue was an awkwardly long
in some parts like you're watching
improv and they don't know when to shut
up you're like now's the time flash the
red light do that comedy thing flash the
light but there was no light we just had
to sit and watch it I thought Cameron
Diaz and Jason Segel worked well in the
movie especially together good chemistry
Cameron Diaz still looks great Olli how
old is she now doesn't matter she's sexy
as hell
Jason Segel even lost that weight I
always found him as the weird pudgie
funny friend and movies like this but
the dude's lost weight good job Jason
Segel I just like seeing people get
healthy and it's good for you this movie
has twists and turns that are so sharp
it's like 90-degree angle turns I just
feel like this movie didn't know what
kind of comedy it wanted to be what's
the point of this mood I feel like this
movie could have been 45 but it could
have been one episode of a show Thank
You comedy yeah a couple in that comedy
gets their sex video uploaded to a few
iPads and now
I gotta go get him before their friends
- perfect - half an hour funny episode
of something hour and a half long movie
I don't know about that I just kind of
nothing to the movie I chuckles in a
couple of parts one part or two it was
funny but in the end I was just like I'm
gonna watch this movie and I'm gonna get
out of this movie and then I'm gonna go
home and make a video about this movie I
was plotting my day as I was watching
this movie I'm not gonna take up too
much of your time on this movie this
movie was chuckle worthy in a couple
scenes it was kind of messy didn't know
where it wanted to go sadly this is a
sex tape you're not gonna remember in
t-minus one day yep already forgot
there's a sex tape have you seen it what
did you think about it whatever you
thought comment below let me know and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more
[Music]